leave you mentioned in a phone call with me that when the cancer settles down, we will address some
of the other issues. How will I know when the cancer settles down? Would you be able to address
neuropathy with the right machine? So there are some issues that you can do simultaneously, of course.
So let's say if I have cancer and let's say my cancer is really active, so I'm really working hard,
you know, with most of my protocols to deal with the cancer, but I also have an autoimmune issue.
Sometimes it's difficult to address that autoimmune issue at the same time, at least to a certain
degree. Why? Because if we're stimulating your immune system to kill the cancer,
we could also be, and many times, we are stimulating the immune system to cause the autoimmune
disease to be more layered. So if I have cancer, I want to stimulate the immune system to kill
the cancer, but if I have an autoimmune disease, if I do things that stimulate the immune system,
I'm going to cause more self-destruction. So in that case, it'd be hard to,
you know, but you could still make some changes like, well, let's look at food sensitivities that
could be stimulated by a immune system that's not helping my cancer, that could actually be hindering
my cancer. Well, I would be helping my autoimmune disorder then by doing that. So we can still
concurrently treat some things, but like cancer and autoimmune disease is more difficult.
Other things like cancer and, you know, stomach issues or cancer and, you know,
bowel issues or cancer and infections, cancer and parasites, very easily treated concurrently,
it can be, you know, combined to what could be totally causing the person issues.
Cancer and neuropathy, same thing. So are there frequencies on the right for neuropathy? Yes,
if you look at the alphabetical list, there are some frequencies for neuropathy.
What else can be done for neuropathy? So neuropathy, remember, is, so if a person has neuropathy
that's induced by chemotherapy, induced by this poison that they took into kill their cancer,
well, that poison damaged the peripheral nerves because it's settling in there. I think I had
to talk about neuropathy a few weeks ago on a Zoom call, helping detox that is going to be helpful.
And then stimulating the nerves is essential.
Other, the most common reason for neuropathy is diabetic-induced neuropathy. So high levels of blood
sugar, the nerves are very sensitive to that and can be damaged by that quite easily. And it's
going to be the peripheral nerves where that blood is going to pool, where the sugar is going to pool,
where the damage is going to occur. So it's going to be neuropathy of the peripheral nerves,
farthest from the heart. So you have to stimulate the nerves in order to wake them up,
in order to get them to grow, in order to get them to heal. So stimulating the nerves can be done
concurrently with treating cancer. There's no contraindication there. You could use tools like vibration
to stimulate the nerves. We see a lot of diabetic neuropathy patients in the past. We'd have
them get these little vibration footplates that I don't know if they're available on Amazon anymore,
but they used to be like a couple hundred bucks or 150 bucks on Amazon, and they just vibrate.
And you could put them by your chair that you sit down at, watch TV or whatever, and you just turn it
on and it just vibrate in and you get put your feet out there with just your socks on, not your shoes.
And it's vibrating, stimulating those nerves. So stimulating nerves is what causes them
to fire and causes them to grow. So your peripheral nerves have receptors that are for hot and cold.
So putting your feet in hot water and cold water is very good. So you have hot and cold receptors.
You have vibratory receptors and those stimulating those are beneficial. And then you can stimulate
them with electrical therapy as well. So there's a tool called the Rebuilder. It's a tool that we've
sold for, oh gosh, a decade or so for neuropathy. That's all it's for. And it stimulates the nerves at
their frequency. Electrically, you have to get a split bath of water so you get one of those like
tote things that you can buy at Walmart. And on our store, you can buy the Rebuilder. And it shows
a picture of what you should buy at Walmart, these little tote things. And you put the rubber pads,
one at each side, fill it with water, put your feet in there and you turn the Rebuilder on it.
You'll feel this tingle like a little electrical stem. You can't, you're not going to electrocute
yourself. It's only a nine little battery. But you're running this thing. You turn it up to tolerance
and you're stimulating those nerves for 15 to 30 minutes a day. And it really does work. It is,
is an FDA approved device for neuropathy. It really does work. So that's another thing that you could
use for neuropathy.